c'est magnifique ça déconne et alors il
faut un petit peu froid
enfin il fait un petit peu froid alors
attention
venez venez me valérie venait alors
attention voilà ils sont là voici le
premier ils vont faire un premier
plongeon c'est jean michel qui va
démarrer le plongeon c'est sa jambe il
commence par le talon on va commencer
par charleroi chamerois chamerois
bertrand chamerois va faire le premier
plongeon dans la piscine
on aura la vie de labeur la raquette
vous plaisir attention premier plongeon
de bertrand chamerois qui demanda
peignoir a juste après attention est
attaché au fait gaffe comme un vrai
attachement non non mais il est fou
c'est qu'un malade c'est un jeu les
faits c'est un fou sans décoller alors
jean michel maire jean michel mr
attention alors qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé du plongeon à il était un temps va
y avait d'un train mais je pense tu peux
faire mieux quoi aller j'ai envie chez
le maire attend ce regard des motifs
logeant au t-shirt attention râteau sur
jean-michel correct blesse pas de
blessés pas beau jour d'hui te blesse
pas bonjour mr
non mais ça fout mais sa balade mais
sans déconner quand même
savage aux savanes jean michel jean
michel est ce que ça va c'est vrai
monsieur thème boubetra jeu s'ébroue de
soleil bon c'était alors à l'homme et sa
malades
non mais vous êtes malade qu'est ce que
quoi alors est ce que tu te sort de ceux
de plongée si tu es avec moi oui le tro
t 1 jusque là et alain bernard
il doit ambitionner c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi
attention fais gaffe des gaffes à las
vegas que tu es très grande noblesse pas
te blesse pas te plaise pas nan on
arrête ton à la bernard hinault missiles
je serai plus 31 quoi qu'il arrive
merci alain verdin